yesterday for this segment of the show
we spent approximately four and a half
hours responding to a couple of obscure
libertarian youtubers may have seemed
like overkill but then again if you
listen frequently you know that i could
easily do an entire show on one tick
tock video that annoyed me so it's all
par for the course today for our daily
cancellation we're gonna
uh we're going somewhere slightly less
obscure but still libertarian i hadn't
planned to dump on the libertarians so
much this week but that's the way it's
working out and
i think i find libertarians so
especially annoying because
we have a few significant things in
common
and yet ultimately they're still so
wrong when it comes down to it and
that's where the frustration comes from
for me
the libertarians are singing my tune
when they talk about abolishing the
income tax or
massively decreasing the size of the
federal government
they tend to be skeptical of the
government education system which is
good and protective of gun rights
they are generally pretty consistent
constitutionalists all of these things
are good
they may take it a bit too far sometimes
like not all taxation is theft for
example just most of it is but still we
line up pretty closely on those issues
things fall apart when we move from
economic and strictly constitutional
issues over to
cultural and moral concerns
here libertarianism begins to quickly
break apart
and the libertarian is left out in the
cold in the dark confused not sure which
way to go
his ideology is not robust enough to
account for the full scope of the human
experience
he was mostly right about those economic
constitutional issues
but he was right for if not the wrong
reasons that at least incomplete reasons
he wants to pay fewer taxes and keep his
guns and so on because of liberty and by
liberty he simply means
his own personal ability to do whatever
he wants because he wants to do it
there are fuller and sturdier reasons to
be in favor of gun rights and against
overtaxation
but those generally are not his reasons
and so when he encounters the deeper
issues the moral issues he has only his
kind of
libertine do what you want mentality to
fall back on
this is when he starts shouting slogans
like let people enjoy things and the
government shouldn't legislate morality
except that literally all legislation
legislates morality
all laws by definition are rooted in a
moral code
they may be wrongly rooted or rooted in
the wrong moral code but completely
amoral laws would be laws passed without
concern at all for whether they're
actually right or wrong
legislation that doesn't attempt to
legislate morality would be by
definition arbitrary
the libertarian doesn't seem to fully
understand this fact and as for letting
people enjoy things the fact is that
enjoyment is not in and of itself
enough
to justify any act
if we're determining whether an act
should be legal or even simply whether
it's good aside from the legal question
we need to ask more than just do people
enjoy
it and when it comes to that enjoyment
we also need to reflect on the nature of
the act and consider the sort of
pleasure that's being derived from it
take almost any self-destructive and
harmful act and you'll find people who
enjoy it that is they take pleasure
however however twisted from it
should we simply leave people to their
self-destructive pleasures even if the
pursuit of that pleasure is actually
making them miserable and causing
despair in the long run
these are all questions that
libertarianism cannot answer and refuse
us to even consider
and that long preamble brings us to an
article in the libertarian reason
magazine written by writer elizabeth
nolan brown titled the new campaign for
a sex-free internet
it's a lengthy article that can't be
fully analyzed in this segment but the
basic gist is that brown is upset about
the fact that due to rule changes over
at sites like pornhub
fewer amateur wannabe porn stars are
able to [ __ ] themselves and their
bodies out for a quick buck
brown is deeply concerned that there is
now a tragic scarcity of whoring on the
internet so reading out says for more
than a decade both amateurs and
professionals shared their sometimes
sweet sometimes weird and often graphic
sexual activity on pornhub
launched in 2007 not long after youtube
and with a similar free-for-all spirit
the site represented a new wave of adult
entertainment in which anyone with an
internet connection could partake and
anyone with a digital camera could
become a star
now a quick sidebar here we have already
started on a precarious note with the
writer's claim that the graphic sexual
content on pornhub is sometimes sweet
i would have thought that sweet would be
something like i don't know bringing
flowers home for your wife just because
i wouldn't think of it as like humping
somebody on camera and posting it to the
internet for profit
maybe i just have an old-fashioned sense
of romance probably so
continuing dubbed tube sites pornhub and
its various peers began to dominate web
traffic generally in porn consumption
specifically these sites
trod on porn's established business
model but for savvy sex workers the tube
site rep network could provide a way to
break into the business or reach
audiences directly without the porn
industry's usual middlemen
to monetize one's presence in the early
days took some creativity but tube sites
would eventually offer content
partnerships that allowed people to get
paid directly for their videos
their competitors such as cam sites and
clip stores made the process of charging
money and getting paid even smoother
oh yes just kind of reflecting
nostalgically on the good old days
brown here speaks wistfully and
longingly about the time when many
thousands or even millions of people
um who would have otherwise been shut
out of the porn industry were able to
break into it with the help of the
internet monetizing their sexual
activity and auctioning their bodies off
to the highest bidder or the lowest
bidder or just any bitter at all
in previous generations you know some of
those people
unable to become porn stars
may have ended up
getting an education instead or training
somewhere taking up a trade becoming
entrepreneurs
entering some other more productive
profession
but pornhub saved them from that dark
path
and that was very good brown says
because
quote
for the first time people with a truly
diverse array of body types looks races
ethnicity sexuality gender identities
and kinks had direct access to the tools
of porn production and distribution in
the past porn had catered to a much more
narrow range of tastes with predictable
results
now audiences could access all sorts of
content
that defied conventional notions
conventional notions of who and what was
deserving of lust
on sites like pornhub and the
microblogging platform tumblr outside
the mainstream content thrived
now we'll return to that passage in just
a moment
but first let's continue on a little
farther as we get to the tragic moments
where everything fell apart and this is
the moment that brown so deeply laments
it says quote and then one day it was
gone in december 2020 without warning
pornhub removed all videos posted by
unverified users a massive cachet of
content encompassing anything not posted
by formal content partners or members of
the platform's official model program
more than 10 million videos were
suspended and unf verified users were
banned from uploading or downloading new
videos
it was more than a disruption to the
site i almost feel like we need sad
piano music in the background here the
unannounced disappearing of so many
videos was a huge cultural loss says
ashley a transgender sex worker and
civil rights activist with a robust
presence on social media often and in
offline organizing
the pornhub purge came about two years
after tumblr's ban on any content
depicting sex acts and preceded a
similar announcement in summer 2021 from
only fans
then in september 2021 the first user
uploaded uploaded pornsite x tube
founded in 2006 and now owned by the
same parent company shut down entirely
tragedy
now there are still billions of smut
videos online but it's uh i mean
literally billions of them
but it's a huge cultural loss
that we're missing
a few of them now she says
she um mourns over the fact that prior
to all of these
amateur cyber prostitutes being kicked
out of the club porn was on its way to
being truly equitable with a diverse
array of body types looks races
ethnicities sexualities etc etc all
represented by porn
now what's of course lost in this is any
sense of what is actually good
the writer being a dedicated libertarian
doesn't concern herself with such
questions
instead she simply declares that if
people are doing a certain thing
and if they seem to be deriving any
pleasure from it
then it's best if everyone is able to do
it equally and equitably
the fact that whoring yourself on the
internet brings despair and hopelessness
and leads so often to substance abuse
and suicide
is irrelevant to her
if a group of people are marching off of
a cliff
and they seem to have smiles on their
faces while they're doing it she just
wants to make sure that the group is
demographically representative of the
overall population
again the concept of the good what is
good
is lost
and that is always lost
by libertarians and and generally by the
culture
and of course what one of their
rejoinders here one of their responses
is well who defines good what is good
how can you define that
yeah we do have to talk about what the
good means
but are you saying that a word like
liberty or freedom or human rights
is that any clearer to you than good
run into the same problem how do you
define that
it's not like there's some sort of
unanimous agreement on what any of those
words mean
in fact the fact that we cannot agree on
what those words means is like tearing
our culture apart right now
but and so instead they just rather than
talking about what good means and uh
concerning themselves whether they just
discard it entirely let's not even worry
about what's actually good
and that brings us to the most revealing
phrase of all that we get in that uh in
that article which is deserving of lust
deserving of lust
now
i can see why people would want to be
deserving of love
love is fulfilling it's edifying there
is joy in love in fact there isn't joy
anywhere but in love there's no joy
outside of love
but lust by itself
is the reduction of a person to the
level of an object
that's what lust is especially the lust
uh in that you find with pornography on
the internet
the person who's doing the lusting they
don't recognize the image on the screen
they don't see that person as a person
it's just an object that is there to
gratify them
that is lust down to its basis level
it's
objectification
treating a person like an object
if you're an object of lust apart from
love
then you're being coveted the way that a
person might covet a consumer good like
a car or a new pair of shoes
should this actually be anyone's goal
the fact that certain people are being
deprived of the opportunity to be
objectified by strangers on the internet
to be treated like an object
um absent of their of their personhood
is this something that we should be
striving for
is it a tragedy that people are being
deprived of it
do we have a right to it
well this is the kind of nonsense that
libertarianism so often descends into
and that is ultimately why
um the writer of this article whose name
i've already forgotten last name brown
is today canceled
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends